شكرا يا ميسون اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا
الكرام الى هذه التغطيه المستمره من
العربيه لليوم السابع لزلزال تركيا وسوريا
جهود جباره لم تعرف الكلل ولا الملل في
عمليات البحث عن ناجين تحت الانقاض
فالدقائق وحتى الثواني ثمينه جدا هناك
امام عقارب ساعه باتت تسير بالجهه
المعاكسه وكلما مر الوقت كلما تبددت
الامال واصبحت فرص النجاه قليله وحتى
عمليه اغاثه من نجوا من الزلزال ستكون
معقده مع ضخامه الاعداد وهو ما اقرت به
منظمه الصحه العالميه
قمنا بتوزيع 110 اطنان من الامدادات
الطبيه على المناطق المتضرره في جميع
انحاء سوريا ومن المقرر ان تصل الليله
طائره الى دمشق مزوده بالامدادات الصحيه
الطارئه المتخصصه والتي تعتبر حيويه
للعاملين في الخطوط الاماميه وهم يتعاملون
مع الاصابات بالاضافه الى ذلك نحن ندعم
زياده قدره الفرق الطبيه المتخصصه في
الخطوط الاماميه منظمه الصحه العالميه
تعمل في جميع المناطق المتضرره وتزيد من
التوسع في انحاء البلاد بما في ذلك في
الشمال الغربي واليوم اطلقنا نداء لجمع 43
مليون دولار لدعم استجابه منظمه الصحه في
كلا البلدين
[موسيقى]
بالليل الساعه 4:00 العصر يا طالعون
مجيد عن مستشفى مرتين
[موسيقى]
اصابات من الزلزال اصابات كانت شديده
للاسف المرضى اللي عم يطلعوا من تحت
الانقاط في عندهم كان هرس عضله هذا الامر
عمل عبء كتير علينا لانه نحن بالاساس ما
عنا هاي المستلزمات دعارات التحالب الدموي
وهي دارات مكلفه
[موسيقى]
عرض مشفى الامومه
تصدعات كبيره تم بفضل الله عز وجل اخلاء
المرضى والكادر بالسرعه القصوى للحفاظ على
سلامتهم
[موسيقى]
وفي الوقت الذي تتضارب فيه التصريحات حول
وصول المساعدات وفتح المعابر الحدوديه بين
تركيا وسوريا الى الشمال السوري هناك
ثلاثه معابر تعد شريان الحياه لاكثر من
اربعه ملايين شخص في شمال سوريا ابرزها
معبر باب الهوى الوحيد في شمال ادلب لعبور
المساعدات الانسانيه الى سوريا بموجب قرار
مجلس الامن الدولي وتسيطر عليه المعارضه
وهناك معبر باب السلامه ويقع في منطقه
اعزاز شمل حلب وتسيطر عليه فصائل المعارضه
السوريه واخيرا معبر جرابلس الواقع فيري
في حلب والذي تسيطر عليه ايضا فصائل
معارضه السوريه
من بلده حارم مع ناس صحفيه مسلم السيد
عيسى اهلا بك معنا مجددا في هذه التغطيه
كيف تسير الان جهود الاغاثه
لمن نجا بعد هذا الزلزال كيف يمكن ان تنقل
لنا هذه الصوره تحديدا في مرحله ما بعد
عمليات الانقاذ
الواقع بشكل تدريجي ربما حتى هذه اللحظه
تقريبا دخلت اكثر من 68 شاحنه عبر المعابر
الحدوديه وهي كما ذكرتم معبر باب الهوى
ومعبر باب السلامه وايضا معبر الحمام وهي
تتبع لمناطق المعارضه بين الحدود السوريه
والتركيه هذه المعابر استقبلت هذه
الشاحنات وتم نقل ما فيها الى الشاحنات
التي تتبع للمنظمات السوريه المحليه لبدء
بتوزيعها طبعا تم تنفيذ عده توزيع عده
حملات توزيع لهذه المواله التي وصلت وبقيه
الشاحنات التي وصلت تنتظر توزيعها على
المخيمات لكن هناك حاله فوضى حقيقه تعيش
هنا في هذه المنطقه نتيجه التخبط الذي
تعيشه المنظمات المحليه اولا بعد افراغ
مؤنها بالكامل وكل مستودعاتها في الايام
الاولى لهذا لهذه الكارثه نتحدث عن انتهاء
تقريبا ساعات قليله على انتهاء اليوم
السابع من هذه الماساه كانت المنظمات
المحليه قد افرغت كل مؤنتها الانسانيه على
النازحين والمهجرين وايضا الموجودين قرب
بنيتهم المهدمه بدا اليوم بمعنى ان هذه
المساعدات يعني بتم توزيعها مباشره على
الناس المتضررين اللي بمس الحاجه لها او
ايضا عبر هذه المنظمات بس افهم منك هذه
النقطه اكثر نعم هناك توضيح مهم حقيقه
اولا تتعرض هذه القوافل
وتاخير شديد اولا نتيجه
يعني الحدود والعمليات اللوجستيه ونقل
وادخال هذه
القوافل ثم افراغ هذه الشاحنات الى
الشاحنات السوريه لان الشاحنات التي تدخل
من تركيا يتم افراغ مؤنها في المعابر ثم
تعود الى الاراضي التركيه ويتم افراغها
الى الشاحنات السوريه ثم تنتقل الى
مستودعات ربما المؤسسات سوريا ليتم
توزيعها وبالتالي هذه البيروقراطيه حقيقه
تؤخر وصول المساعدات الى مستحقيها في
المخيمات وفي العراق الاهالي هنا تطالب
بتسريع هذه العمليات تجاوز المراحل
اللوجستيه الطويله وايضا عمليات التشييك
الطويله لاحظت انا كنت في احد المعابر يتم
التشييك من الطرفين يعني سواء فان الطرف
التركي او السوري على كل محتويات هذه
القوافل كم سله اضافيه وكم كرسي وكم الى
اخره من الادويه مخاوف معينه يعني عندهم
امنيه ربما او ماذا
لا اعتقد انها مخاوف امنيه مرتبطه
بالمخاوف الامنيه انما هي اجراءات روتينيه
متواجده في المعابر لكن لا تناسب المرحله
الحاليه يعني هذه
الاجماليه المراحل او بالايام العاديه
لدخول القوافل الانسانيه لكن اليوم
الاهالي والمنظمات الانسانيه تطالب بتسريع
هذه العمليات حتى المساعدات باسرع وقت
ممكن حتى تدخل المساعدات الاخرى التي سترد
يعني ايضا في الساعات والايام المقبله
بالضبط وهذا ما
تتاخر للوصول الى الداخل السوري هل تشمل
هذه المساعدات كل ما يحتاجه الناس او على
الاقل اهم ما يحتاجه الناس ما المطالب
نعم المساعدات التي وصلت كما ذكرت تقريبا
هي قرابه السبعين شاحنه تحتوي على كامل
تقريبا الاحتياجات الطارئه من ادويه من
احتياجات للمستشفيات وايضا من سلات غذائيه
وخيام وغيرها لكن انا اليوم جلد بين
الكثير من الناس المتواجدين على انقاذ
منازلهم وفي شوارع وطرقات قالوا انهم
اوى الى اشياء
للتحمل الجو الطقس الطقس البارد الحالي
نتحدث عن درجات تتقارب من الصفر وهذه
العوائل تفترش الساحات والطرقات العامه
وبالتالي تحتاج الى مواد تدفئه عاجله حتى
تتجاوز فقط اليومين القادمين من هذه
الموجه النقطه الثانيه
ركزت الاها لانها تحتاج الى مراكز ايواء
حتى يتم نقلهم لاحقا الى ربما قرى سكنيه
او غيرها بحسب هل هذا ممكن هل في وعود من
الجهات المعنيه بذلك بامكانيه تامين مواد
التدفئه والبطانيات لبعض المساعدات التي
يعني لا يركز عليها حاليا هل هناك قدره
لذلك
نعم بالنسبه للمنظمات المحليه تقوم بكامل
جهودها لكن تنتظر هي الوعود يعني تواصلت
مع الكثير من المؤسسات المحليه قالت ان
هناك وعود من المؤسسات الحكوميه السعوديه
والقطريه وايضا التركيه بادخال مساعدات
يوم غد مخصصه لحالات الطوارئ هذه بانتظار
يعني تامين المرحله الثانيه وهي تامين هذه
العوائل في مراكز ايواء نحن نتحدث عن هذه
العوائل تفترش الاراضي الزراعيه الساحات
العامه وغيرها دون وجود اي اماكن تستقبل
هذه العوائل لان هذه العوائل هناك نقطه
جدا مهمه نزحت عشرات المرات حتى استقرت في
هذه المنازل التي دمرت اليوم بفعل هذا
الزلزال فهي لا تملك اي مقومات لتمالك
نفسها يعني ان تعيش يوم اضافي فقط قال لي
احد الرجال يومه رب اسره مكونه من عشره
افراد قال لي انا لا املك في جيبي دولار
واحد فقدت كل ما املك في منزلي وبالتالي
لم يستطيع تقديم حتى ماده الخبز لاطفاله
والاطفال وذويه الموجودين معهم بالتالي
هذه الحاله ربما تعمم على الاف الاسر
الموجوده هنا نحن نتحدث فقط في شمال غرب
سوريا عن اكثر من 30 الف عائله مهجره
وقع ماساوي سيبقى معنا قليلا نامل يعني ان
يتم مراعاه ذلك من قبل المعنيين باسرع وقت
ممكن شكرا جزيلا لك مسلم سيد عيسى الصحفي
من حارم تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
على قيد الحياه كلمه يتجدد معها الامل من
تحت الركام
151 ساعه تحت الانقاض قضاها الشاب عبد
الله تحت ركام منزله المدمر فيها تاي
التركيه متمسكا بالحياه
خرج الى النور بعد سبعه ايام منظومه
الركام مانحا بارقه امل بدات بالتضاؤل مع
اقتراب مرور اسبوع على الكارثه
ومنها طاي الحزينه لم تتوقف قصص النجاه
والصمود
الاربعه وستين عاما لم يهزمها زلزال وقوته
خرجت من بين الركام بعد 150 ساعه عثرت
عليها فرق الانقاذ وتم نقلها الى المستشفى
وسط صدمه وفرحه المنقذين امل ضئيل تجدد
باحتماليه العثور على المزيد من الناجين
وبتجاهل سباق الزمن
جهود فرق الانقاذ المتواصله تمكنت من
انتشار شخص عمره 50 عاما بعد اسبوع من
بقائه تحت الركام في انطاكيا اما الرضيع
ذو الاشهر السبعه فيها الطاي فقضى 140
ساعه تحت الركام قبل ان تنجح فرق اطفاء
تركيه من انقاذه وبين عمليه انقاذ واخرى
يقف العشرات من الاهالي الناجين بملامح
تعكس الما كبيرا يتجمهرون حول فرق الانقاذ
متشبسين بمعجزه العثور على احياء ملوك
الشيخ العربيه
الله الله اكبر
مشاهد الدمار على مدار اسبوع من كارثه
الزلزال قاسيه قرى سوريه سويت بالارض ومدن
منكوبه تركيه تحتاج مليارات دولارات لتقوم
مجددا من خلال محاكاه افتراضيه نعود
بالزمن الى الوراء للحظه نادرا ما ترصدها
الكاميرات في التقرير الاتي مع الزميله
حنين الشولي
انقضاء الساعات الثقيله يصبح ما بعدها
اثقل
ويصبحوا هذا المشهد حلما وماضيا في اذهان
ووجداني من عاصر الدقيقه الفارقه او اقصر
هكذا كانت المدينه قبل الكارثه واللحظه
القادمه نادرا ما توثقها عدسه اللح
ظه تنشا فيها بؤره زلزال تحت هذه الارض لا
التي اقف عليها بل في المركز على بعد
عشرات الكيلومترات وعمق ثلاثمائه كيلومترا
واكثر هنا لدرجه الزلزال الدور الاكبر هذه
هزه اولى بقوه 6 درجات او هزه ارتداديه
بقوه خمس درجات
لاحقت زلزالا يفوقها قوه في درجه على
الاقل علميا الهزه اقل وطئه لكن هذا البيت
لم يسقط تداعى وانهار بحكم قدمه او سوء
معايير بناءه كارثه قد تحل بعشرات السكان
وربما بعض الماره ليسوا ارقاما بل الارواح
كانت امنه قبل ان تفاجئها الطبيعه
لكن امامك كارثه اكبر بالمقاييس والعواقب
ينظر الى دمار منزل او اثنين على انه
اضرار ضئيله وما سنوشك على محاكاته الان
نكبه عاشتها هايتي في 2010 كاليفورنيا
الامريكيه عام 89 تشيلي عامي 60 و 2010
وبقاع اخرى وقف سكانها المحظوظون منهم
امام خراب وترك الالاف ضحايا تحت الالقاب
هذا ما حل بجنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا بعد
هذه اللحظه كل دقيقه بحساب وكل ثانيه
بنفسه هناك كانت غرفه النوم وهناك غرفه
المعيشه او المطبخ او الباب
كل ما كان اصبح ركاما يتسابق الوقت لرفعه
مع الموت والحياه الانقاذ والانقاذ
الامل والالم
[موسيقى]
معنى من جنديرس الصحفي محمد الاشقر اهلا
بك معنا محمد كيف يمكن ان نتخيل شكل
الايام المقبله في عمليات الاغاثه لمن نجى
امكنه الايواء المستشفيات الميدانيه نقل
المساعدات وكيف يمكن توزيعها بشكل عادل
على محتاجيها
نعم ان بدات الحديث على المستوى الطبي فان
اكثر الاطباء طلبا في المشافي هنا نتيجه
لعلاج المصابين الناجين من تحت الانقاض هم
اطباء العصبيه والاوعيه وايضا
العظميه هؤلاء الاطباء نتيجه عددهم القليل
في الشمال السوري ربما منذ بدايه هذه
الكارثه الى حد هذه اللحظه لا يرتاحون الى
بضع ساعات فنحن في الشمال غرب سوريا ما
شافي شمال غرب سوريا تحتاج للامداد
لاطباء لهذه
الاختصاصات ايضا مشافي الشمال تحتاج
لاجهزه ومعدات طبيه لمدها
لاستيعاب هذا العدد الهائل من المصابين
بالاضافه لحاجتها للادويه والمستهلكات
الطبيه ان تحدثنا عن الناجين الذين لجاوا
الى مخيمات
عليها كثيرا طبعا
ضيفنا قبل قليل كان اتحدث عن اهميه هذا
الموضوع التزويد بالبطانيات وبمواد
التدفئه الان انت تنقل لنا الحاجه الى
اطباء متخصصين ايضا والى ان يعني
تتوفر مراكز الايواء على ما يلزمها من
حاجيات اساسيه هل يعني رصدت ايضا كما نقل
لنا ضيفنا قبل قليل من جانبك حاله فوضى في
توزيع المساعدات وتاخير كبير في تفتيشها
نعم يعني في الحقيقه هنا في مدينه جنديرس
يعني
المساعدات التي دخلت من خارج سوريا هي
يعني مساعدات المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مركز الملك سلمان التي دخلت يوم امس من
معبر حمام طبعا دخلت الى مدينه جنديرس
وبدا التوزيع واستهداف المتضررين في هذا
اليوم يعني تحدثنا مع منظمه الامين شريكه
مركز الملك سلمان وقالوا لنا انهم سيبداون
منذ صباح غد بنصب خيام لاستيعاب جميع
الناجين من من هذا الزلزال في مدينه
جنديرس وسيتم تامين كافه مستلزمات الخيام
لهم وتامين وتزويدهم بسلى الاغاثيه غذائيه
وسيله للنظافه طبعا هذا هذه تطبيق احد
العاملين في منظمه ما العدد الذي تكفيه
نعم قال سيستهدفون نعم لم يحدد لم يحدد
عددا ولكن قال بانهم سيبداون غدا باستهداف
جميع الناجين من الزلزال في مدينه جنديرس
ومحيطها يعني
ايضا هناك العديد من المنظمات الانسانيه
المحليه التي تهافتت الى مدينه جنديرس
بالاضافه للفرق التطوعيه الشبابيه
والمبادرات الاهليه المحليه هنا في مدينه
جنديرس يعني
لتزويد الناجين بما يلزمهم يعني من من
طعام يعني الطعام متوفر يعني صراحه ما
شاهدته هنا في مدينه جنديرس اليوم ان
الطعام متوفر وبكثره للجميع للفرق العامله
سواء في انتشال الضحايا او الفرق الطبيه
او حتى
الاهالي الذين يعني بعضهم عاد الى منازلهم
الغير مدمره بشكل كامل ما الذي يوفرها
يعني اخذ بعض من حوائج من الذي يوفرها
يعني هم هم
نعم نعم طبعا هذا الطعام مختلف المنظمات
الانسانيه المحليه والفرق التطوعيه
والمبادرات الاهليه هي من تقوم بالتوزيع
يعني لفت انتباهي ان احد الناجين من
الزلزال الذين قمنا كنا نقوم بالبث
المباشر من جانب خيمته التي نصبها امام
منزله المدمر بشكل جزئي
يقدم الشاي للماره من امام خيمته يعني
لتدفئتهم في ظل البرد القارص يعني في
الحقيقه خلايا نحل تعمل هنا في مدينه
جنديرس لاستيعاب هذه الكارثه في يومها
السابع وساعات قليله تفصلنا عن دخول اليوم
الثامن لبدء هذه الكارثه يعني
هل العدد الاكبر الطبي فقد كيف يمكن ان
نميز الاعداد بين من استطاع وتمكن ان يعود
الى منزله اللي منزله لا تزال صالحه اللي
منازله متصدعه يعني يمكن المخاطره فيها
لانه بعضهم خاطر كما سمعنا في في مناطق
معينه تعرضت للزلزال او تلك المهدده
المقدمه تماما
نعم يعني في الحقيقه الموضوع هنا في مدينه
جرد جنديرس يحتاج للجان تقييم خبيره ولكن
بحسب جولاتنا ضمن احياء المدينه فان اكثر
من 80% من منازل هذه المدينه غير صالحه
للسكن اما تدمرت بشكل كلي وسميت بالارض او
تضررت بشكل جزئي ولكن هناك عامل اساسي
يعني حتى المنازل الغير متضرره هناك حاله
خوف شديده عند الاهالي من العوده لمنازلهم
هناك العديد منهم من اختار البقاء في
العراء مقابل ان يعودوا الى منازلهم خصوصا
ان المنطقه تتعرض لهزات ارتداد ارتداديه
طبعا حاله الخوف هذه مركزه بنسبه كبيره
عند الاطفال يعني اغلب الاطفال الذين
التقينا بهم نسالهم لماذا لا تعودون الى
المنزل قالوا انهم يفضلون الخيمه طبعا
الخيمه الخيام
12 عاما منذ بدايه
يعني حرب النظام على شعبه هنا على شعب
السوري
ومناشدات تنطلق من شمال غرب سوريا
لايجاد حل جذري لسكان الخيام وانهاء
معاناتهم
انا اشكرك على هذه المعلومات اعذرني هذه
محمد الاشقر صحفي من جنديرس شكرا جزيلا لك
تحياتنا اليك
اعتقلت سلطات التركيه عشرات المقاولين
الذين يشتبه بمسؤوليتهم عن انهيار المباني
جراء الزلزال الذي وقع الاسبوع الماضي وفي
سياق متصل قال وزير العدل انه جرى منع سفر
اكثر من 150 شخصا من المسؤولين عن تشييد
مباني انهارت بفعل الزلزال
لحظات انكشفت مداها شاشه المباني في
المناطق المتضرره من زلزال تركيا والسلطات
تحاول احتواء الغضب الشعبي في هذه المناطق
قوات الامن نفذت حمله اعتقالات طالت عشرات
المقاولين والمهندسين واعلن وزير العدل
التركي بكير بوزداج انشاء مكتب للتحقيق في
جرائم الزلزال وما تبعه من وفيات واصابات
كما كشف الوزير عن اعتقال 62 من مقاولي
البناء فيما قالت وكاله انباء الاناضول ان
عدد المعتقلين تجاوز المئه في المقاطعات
العشره التي طالها الزلزال
تركيا سبق لها ان شددت قوانين البناء بعد
زلزال ازميت شمال غرب البلاد عام
1999 والذي قتل فيه 17 الف شخص المعايير
التي تم تحديثها عام 2018 تستلزم استخدام
هياكل مصنوعه من خرسانه عاليه الجوده
مدعمه بقضبان فولاذيه وعلى ان توزع
الاعمده الامتصاص تاثير الزلازل بشكل فعال
لكن رغم المعايير المفروضه قدمت السلطات
اعفاءات للمباني المنشاه دون شهادات
السلامه المطلوبه على ان يتم دفع رسوم
مقابل عدم الالتزام الاعفاءات هذه لقيه
انتقادات داخليه وحذر منتقدون من ان
التهاون في قوانين البناء قد يؤدي لكارثه
حال وقوع زلزال كبير في الجانب البحري
نقلت صحيفه حريات ديلين نيوز عن استاد
جيولوجيا بجامعه اسطنبول قوله ان اختيار
اماكن البناء جرى بشكل غير علمي مست
بزلزال كايكور نيوزلنديه عام 2016 الذي
بلغت قوته 7.8 درجه وادى حينها لمقتل
شخصين واصابه 57 اخرين
اما اعلم اسطنبول البحث في الشان التركي
اهلا بك معنا استاذ طه بخصوص
اعتقالات المقاولين ومنع السفر والى ما
هنالك هل هذه محاوله لامتصاص نقمه الناس
انه المتداول فعلا او اذا كان في ادله اذا
كان في معلومات ما حتى الان بانه يمكن ان
يكون تورطوا فعلا بما زاد الطين بله على
الناس بعد الزلزال
الشارع التركي نتحدث عن كارثه انسانيه
كبيره تمرت عشر المقاطعات في تركيا الى
حتى اللحظه الجميع هو يعني في حاله يعني
التعبير لم يقلق من هذه الصدمه من شغل
فيما يتعلق بالبحث عن ناجين حتى هذه
اللحظات نلاحظ دائما معجزات ولكن فيما
يتعلق بموضوع المقاولين واعتقال نعم هي
حاليا هناك الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان اعترف
في الايام الاولى من حاله من التقصير
وخاصه فيما يتعلق بموضوع المساعدات ولكن
موضوع البناء وتشييد البناء اعتقد سوف
يكون مدار نقاش علاقات النقاش خلال
المرحله المقبله خاصه تحدثنا عن ان هناك
العديد من البباني ان كانت في مصر الكبرى
وحتى في المناطق التي شهدت زلز فيها
ان هناك يعني مساكن جديده وانهارت يعني
بسرعه وحتى ولكن ما الذي يقال عندكم من
الخبراء ان كان في الزلازل او بالهندسه
الانشائيه هل هناك مشكله حقيقيه في البناء
في الابنيه نفسها يعني لم يكن هناك التزام
بالمعايير التي تضعها الحكومه والوزارات
المتخصصه في هذا الاطار
الى حتى هذه اللحظه التحقيقات ما زالت
مستمره وخاصه من وزاره العدل ولكن كل هذه
الامور يعتقد يعني سوف تطلع خلال ايام
المقبله نعم هناك بعض يعني
الشخصيات والمقاورين وان يقوم احد
المقاولين بالعرب هو زوجته خارج تركيا
اعتقد هذه هي بانه هو كان يحاول قدر
الامكان عدم الالتزام بالمعايير التي
تضعها الدوله وهناك الكثير من الامور
الغامضه سوف تنكسر جليا خلال المرحله
المقبله لكن هذا يعني سيجر الموضوع الى
قيادات اخرى والى مسؤولين اخرين ربما
يكونون قد تورطوا في ذلك الحكومه ستكون
امام يعني حمله
تطهير بين قوسين لمن تثبت ادانته
صحيح صحيح اليوم المعارضه هناك عنونت
عنوان وسوف يكون العنوان الاقرص الايام
المقبله وهو ليس كارثه العصر اهمال العصر
واعتقد هي تلميح لما هو قادم الجميع حاليا
يصمت بسبب عمليات الانقاذ وانتشال ناشين
ولكن بعد ايام سوف نتابع جميع هناك
الاهمال عفوا البناء العنوان اللي صدر
الصحيفه الابنيه ولا تعطي الحكومه ما بعد
الزلزال يعني حتى اصبح لا استطيع ان اتهم
الحكومه واتهم اي جهه اخرى ولكن هناك بعض
المقاولين المستغلين
التعبير كان في عدد كبير من المدن
يستطيعون
المستقلين او المستقلين
المستغلين المستغلين استغلال يعني ان
يقوم هناك الحكومه تضع بعض
الاشتراك
انهم لميات اقل مسافرين في بعض الامور
وهيا من اجل المكتب الاكثر وهذه هي سوف
تكون يعني اعتقد المعارضه سوف تقوم او
تعرض على البرلمان بعض القضايا وحسب يعني
ما فهمنا وتبعنا اليوم في وسائل الاعلام
التركيه هناك حديث مطول سوف يكون هو في
دائره النقاش خلال الايام والاسابيع
المقبله عن ان الشعب
هذا النقاش هل ستكون في المؤسسات الرسميه
هل سنشهد نقاشا سجالا استجوابا من هذا
النوع في البرلمان هل
حكومه نفسها مهدده بكاملها
يعني
هو
قبل قليل
الجميع كان منشغل بموضوع الناجيه موضوع
يعني هذه الكارثه وهذه المساء ولكن هناك
حتى ان الرئيس اردوغان اعترف بانه هناك
تقصير ويحي تماما بان هناك بعض المفسدين
او الفاسدين حتى في داخل يعني المقربين من
الرئيس اذا اعتقد سوف يكون الحساب كبير
جدا ونتحدث يعني نحن عام انتخابات قريبه
بعد احصر انجنت
انجلت اذا تم اجراءها ولكن على كل الاحوال
هناك سباق وهناك محتدم ما بين الحكومه
والمعارضه اعتقد هذه الفرصه اضرب لك مثال
يعني تتذكر عندما وصل الى السلطه في عام
99 وصل عندما تم اعتقال عبد الله اوجلان
وسقط من الحكومه عندما جاءت
كارثه او زلزال زلزال صحيح وحاليا نعم
وحاليا الرئيس اردوغان هو كسب السلطه في
عام 2002 وعندما كان هناك افلاس الدوله
بالاقتصاد ولكن حاليا نشهد حاليا كيف
سيكون مصير السلطه على اثر الزلزال الحالي
[موسيقى]
نحن سنرصد هذا الموضوع معك ومع بقيه
الزملاء والمحللين والصحفيين من اسطنبول
طه عوده اوغلو البحث في الشان التركي
تحياتي اليك
ينضم الينا من عمان الان الاستاذ في
الهندسه الانشائيه والزلازل في الجامعه
الاردنيه دكتور انيس الشطناوي اهلا بك
دكتور معنا في هذه التغطيه المستمره من
العربيه
كان ملفنا قبل قليل موضوع الاعتقالات ومنع
السفر لمتعهدين
كان سؤالي لضيفنا من تركيا والان اسالك
اياه في اطار التقني المحض هل هناك محاوله
لامتصاص نقمه الناس او انه فعلا كان يمكن
لو تم الالتزام بالمعايير المعروفه دوليا
للبناء ان يتم على الاقل التقليل من حجم
الضرر الذي وقع
حقيقه تصميم الهندسي للمنشات المنشات
والمباني والجسور يخضع
معايير واشتراقات ضمن كودات هندسيه معتمده
في البلدان مختلفه سواء في تركيا او في
غيرها هذه الكودات هي المعيار الاساسي
اللي لازم يلتزم فيه بدايه المصمم الهندسي
حتى انه يصمم منشاه تستطيع ان تقاوم افعال
الزلازل للمنطقه التي يصمم فيها او
للمنشاه التي يصمم فيها وطبعا بيعتمد على
معايير عديده مش فقط على مقدار او قوه
الزلزال اللي بيحصل هو بيعتمد على اوامر
اخرى اللي هي الخطوره الزلزاليه اللي هي
المنطقه اللي موجود فيها الفوالق بس هي
معروفه انه منطقه فوالق ومنطقه بتصير فيها
زلازل كثير ومنطقه بالسنوات الاخيره صار
فيها اصلا زلازل وبال 99 صار في كارثه
كبرى ايضا
لم يكن من
بانه طبيعه ومعايير البناء في تلك المنطقه
تكون مصنفه ومفرزه ومختلفه تماما عن اي
منطقه لا تكون مهدده بالزلازل كي لا تحصد
هذا العدد الكبير من الارواح
بلا شك جميع جميع كودات الزلازل تتضمن
خرائط الخطوره الزلزاليه اللي بتهدد
المناطق ومقدار تاثير الزلازل على
التسارعات الارضيه على فترات اعتزاز
مختلفه وبالتالي الخطوره محدده من خلال
الكودات والمصمم واجبه والتزامه القانوني
ان يلتزم بهذه المعايير وال بمقدار
الخطوره الزلزاليه لتصميم المنشاه حسب نوع
المنشاه وحسب مواد المنشاه او حسب عدد
طوابقه والى اخره وانما المساله هي حقيقه
شائكه لانها بتقع بين مصمم وبين مقاول
وبين رقابه وتفتيش وضبط جوده وبالتالي هي
يرتبط فيها ثلاث عناصر من المسؤوليه
القانونيه ليس عنصر واحد الان اذا بس كانت
ستشفع للناس اكثر لو تم الالتزام يعني حتى
مع الفوق سبع درجات على مقياس ريختر كان
ممكن انه الضرر يكون اقل بكثير لانه
المنطقه معروفه انه منطقه زلازل مثال في
في كاليفورنيا في 89 حصل زلزال
على ريفتر توفى فيه 70 شخص فقط بحين في
ايران في مدينه بامام 2003 حصل زلزال اقل
قوه 6.3 على ريختر وتوفي في
ثلاث هذا طبعا
بعود اللي هي اولها تحديد مقدار الخطر
الزلزالي اللي بيعتمد على الخطوره وعلى
انكشاف وتعرض المباني وكثافه السكان
وكثافه الاقتضاض السكاني وعلى ضعف المباني
اللي بيعتمد اذا احترام شروط البناء بكل
بساطه لانه في منطقه معروفه انها زلزاليه
مثل ما بصير باليابان ولكن مؤمن الى انه
كل البنايات تتعمر بطريقه تراعي الزلازل
مثل دول اخرى ايضا ولكن في بعض الدول مثل
بحاله ايران اللي ذكرتها او في حاله تركيا
الان
وطبعا في حاله سوريا ودول اخرى لم يتم رعد
ذلك على الاطلاق
على الاقل هذه الدول الناميه خلينا نحكي
هي انشات الكودات التصميم متاخرا حقيقه
يعني كودات التصميم ضد افعال الزلازل في
امريكا وفي العالم متقدم نشات مبكرا في
بدايه القرن الماضي عندنا في الشرق الاوسط
حقيقه مثلا مثال في الاردن احنا من 25 سنه
فقط بدانا في تطبيق معايير تصميم لمقاومه
الزلازل وينطبق هذا القول على معظم مناطق
او دول الشرق الاوسط عامه ومنها تركيا
وايران يعني هاي النقطه وصلت بدي اسالك
بعد في خطر بموضوع يعني الهزات زلازل كذا
في شيء يتوقع فيها المجال ولا لا لانه
دائما الجدل قائم منذ بدايه الزلزال اذا
في شيء يتم توقعه في هذا الاطار او لا
والله يا سيدي هو توقع الزلازل يعني اكيد
زملائنا جيولوجيين حكوا كثير في بالاعلام
يعني توقع الوقت الزلزال متى يحدث لا
يستطيع اي انسان ان يحدد هذا الوقت استطيع
ان اتنبا بمكان الزلزال من ناحيه احتمالات
واعصائات المنطقه المحتمل للحصول فيها
زلزال استطيع ان اتنبا بقوه الزلزال اذا
حصل عن طريق السجلات التاريخيه ومعايير
اخرى احصائيه واحتمالات ممكن فيها دراسات
عديده حتى احدد المقدار القوه اللي ممكن
تحصل اما انت ممكن يحصل هذا الزلزال فهذا
امر ما زال
نسبه الخطر بما انه الفوالق الزلزاليه
تحركت بفعل الزلزال
فوالق اخرى تتاثر نعم فوائد المجاوره قد
تتاثر في الفارق الرئيسي اذا حصل في تفريق
طاقه فهو حقيقه بده يفرغ هذه الطاقه بده
يتحرك بده يؤثر على الفوالق الاخرى
وبالتالي ممكن تتحرك نعم بس بقصد يعني بضل
في في امد زمني معروف انه ممكن يضل في خطر
اكثر من غيره او لا حتى اعلاه على الفالق
نفسه يعني اذا على خط الصدع نفسه اذا كان
في بما انه تحرك اذا في امات زمني بضل
مرصود الوضع فيه يعني ممكن يصير في خطر
مادام موجود الفالق الرئيسي او الصدر
الرئيسي الخطر من الحدوث الزلزال موجود
ولكن مساله حدود زلزال رئيسي قوي هو تفريغ
لهذه الطاقه وبالتالي تاريخيا السجلات
تاريخيه اذا حدث زلزال على فائق معين ياخذ
حقيقه بعديها بفترات طويله ممكن تبتدي
لعشرات السنوات حتى يكرر نفسه هذا الزلزال
ممكن تمتد الى مئات السنوات يعني الزلزال
حتى يعيد نفسه في منطقه معينه ممكن ياخذ
مئه سنه 200 سنه 400 سنه وبالتالي لا
يستطيع ان نحكم انه بعد اسبوع ولا عشره
ايام بده يحدث زلزال رئيسي انا ما بتحدث
طبعا عن زلازل الارتداديه اللي بتحصل
تاليه للزلزال الرئيسي
اقل من القوه الزلزال الرئيسيه معلش بس
اسالك رد على يعني كتير من التعليقات اللي
عم نقراها في وسائل التواصل عن ظنون وشكوك
واتهامات يعني ولو جزافا ولكن تذكر بموضوع
انشاء السدود على الانهر بموضوع عمليات
تجارب عسكريه معينه انه يمكن ان تكون
اسهمت في ذلك او في حجم
الخسائر التي حدثت في حجم الزلزال يعني
وبالتالي الخسائر والاضرار
قول العلم في ذلك
يا سيدي اسمه اللي هو جهاز اللي بيسجل
الموجه الزلزاليه ونستطيع من طبيعه هذه
الموجه ان نحكم ما هو السبب في حدوث هذه
الموجه الزلزاليه وانا بعتقد وانا اطلعت
على الموجه الزلزاليه اللي حصلت في تركيا
هي موجه زلزاليه طبيعيه حتى من حركه
الصفائح التكتونيه وليس لها اي علاقه
بموضوع التفجيرات وبالنسبه للسدود اثبتت
الدراسات ان السدود الضخمه تسبب نشاط
زلزالي ولكن بالعاده لا يصل الى هذا هذه
القوه اللي هي 7.5 وانما قد يكون من
الزلازل المتوسطه خمسه الى سته باقصى
حدودها كل الدراسات اشارت 5 الى 6 بس ايضا
قد يكون يعني قاتل خاصه اذا لم تكن
البنايات مؤمنه بشكل اللازم
نعم سيدي نعم وهذا الجزء اللي انا حكيت لك
اياه قبل لحظه اللي هو مساله التخطيط
البنيه التحتيه وتوسع المدن وبناء السدود
والمباني الاستراتيجيه المهمه يجب ان يتم
التخطيط بناء على تقييم الخطوره الزلزاليه
يعني اين نضع هذا السد يجب ان يتم التقييم
المسبق للخطوره الزلزاليه للطبيعه الارضيه
والفوالق المحيطه حتى نحكم هل يناسب هذا
الموقع هذا السد ام لا تعتقد انه لم يتم
مراعاه ذلك اذا كنت يعني درست هذا الموضوع
بموضوع بالتركيه اقصد الدول مثل تركيا
يحكمها الحاجه الاقتصاديه لانتاج الكهرباء
او للحاجات الماء فتضحي حقيقه في مساله
معينه مقابل مساله اخرى تغامر او تاخذ اما
التصميم انا متاكد انه تم مقاوم للزلازل
ولكن هو معرض للخطر باحتمال اكبر من مناطق
اخرى بعيده عن الفوالق بلا شك شكرا جزيلا
لك الاستاذ في الهندسه الانشائيه والزلازل
في الجامعه الاردنيه دكتور انيس الشطناوي
تحياتنا اليك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله
[موسيقى]
لانه الباب كمان
شو اسمك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بسم الله
الوضع هنا صعب للغايه امي واختي ما زالتا
تحت الانقاض ولا استطيع الوصول اليهما باي
شكل من الاشكال انهما تموتان تحت الانقاض
وانا اموته هنا
[موسيقى]
لقد تلاشت امال الان املوا فقط ان يخرجوا
من هنا لا احد يساعد لا اتوقع اي شيء من
الحكومه بعد الان
[موسيقى]
سيدي
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
انطلاق الطائره الاغاثيه السابعه الى
تركيا من مطار الملك خالد الدولي في
الرياض وشملت المساعدات اطنانا من المواد
الايوائيه والمولدات الكهربائيه
[موسيقى]
حسيت ان الارض تتحرك من تحت صارت الحجار
من حوالي والعماره صارت تتحرك
[موسيقى]
اصاله رجفه الارض شوي
الحيطان تمر على الاولاد البنايات عم تهبط
على الارض
[موسيقى]
بس انا الحمد لله ما صابني شيء انا واختي
وطلعنا من البدايه ما بعرف ليش
[موسيقى]
معنى من مدينه حارم في ادلب عاطف نعنوع
مدير فريق الملهم التطوعي اهلا بك معنا
استاذ عاطف كيف تسير عمليات الاغاثه
لمن نجا على الاقل
وما هي ابرز الحاجيات بعد بدء وصول
المساعدات
مساء الخير بالبدايه كل الرحله لشهداء
زلزال والشفاء العاجل الجرحى والله يجزيه
الخير والدفاع المدني والاشخاص اللي
ساهموا في انقاذ
الاشخاص اللي كانوا تحت الركام
بعد انتهاء الانتهاء من عمليات البحث
والانقاذ
انتقلت الناس من الصدمه الاولى لصدمه
الثانيه الصدمه الثانيه اللي كانت هي
عباره عن
صدمتم بالماوى وعنده يروحوا وان كان كل
تركيزهم بعائلاتهم
صدمه للاشخاص اللي اللي
بدهم يخبروا الاطفال للنجوا انه ابوهم
توفوا فانتقلوا للصدمه التانيه وهي تامين
انه نعيش حياه عاديه حياه يعني بمكان ولو
كان خيمه الخيم للاسف معدومه اذا متوفي
معدومه بشكل كامل للاسف بسبب انه كان في
مرحله نوع من الاستقرار ما كان في نزوح
فبف المنظمات الانسانيه ما كانت عم تخزن
انه ما كان في حاجه الى وبالتالي التجار
كمان بنفس الوقت
اثناء الفتره هاي فبالتالي بدا يوصل يعني
بس فهمني شو اللي بدا يوصل ويا ريت هيك
شوي على يمينك لو سمحت لنشوفك مضبوط
حاليا عم يوصل للمنظمات اللي موجوده
بالعكس بالعكس
حاليا
اللي حاليا عم يوصل للمقسمات الانسانيه او
للشمال السوري للشمال السوري عم يوصل
مساعدات غذائيه مساعدات طبيه مساعدات
اساسيه مثل الفرشات والبطانيات وما شابه
للاسف للاسف هاي المساعدات هي جيده
وضروريه ولكن في حال كانوا موجودين الناس
في مكان معين يعني لما انا بدي اتجهنا
مضطر زلزال وين بدي اروح عليهم
ما في ما في ما في مراكز ايواء لم يتم
تاسيس مراكز ايواء بشكل كافي في مراكز
الدواء ولكن غير كافيه فبالتالي الناس
موجودين بالمخيمات عند اقربائهم الناس
موجودين بالطرقات في ناس لليوم مع انه
بيوتهم بس هم لليوم لحد اللحظه موجودين
اما بسيارات قريبين او تحت مبانيهم
بيطلعوا بس يعني بيستخدموا شوي وبرجع
بينزلوا خايفين من السقف
الشيء اللي صار
لانه تصدعت وحتى لو ما تصدعت لانه في ناس
صار عندها هوس اكثر من الف هزي اعتداديه
احنا لما نحكي عنهم انا شخصيا ما عم بقدر
اطلع اقعد ببيت أنا موجود بعزاز
شيء لا يصدق لا يصدق اهوال ما بعد صدمه
طبعا طبعا بدون شك لا لا
اتحرك بحس انه بيتحركوا والله العظيم ما
عم بال ابدا الموضوع مو سهل ابدا الموضوع
النفسي ما بيقل عن الضرر الجسديه يعني
فبالتالي عدا عن الاشخاص الموجودين من
المشافي الاشخاص اللي بحاجه عمليات خاصه
بعض المواد الاساسيه يعني نحن عمليات
عظميه الاطباء بيعملوا العمليات بشكل
مجاني ولكن
اكثر المتضررين او الجرحى او المصابين هن
الاشخاص ذروا عزميا انه بالنهايه عم يوقع
سقف فبالتالي اكيد الحالات موظفه رسميه
الحالات العزميه بحاجه الى انه نشتري لها
قبل العمليه نشتري لها صفائح ونشتري سياخ
ونشتري براغي بحاجه الى لا لا هاي الامور
اصلا غير مدعومه دوليا هي تعتبر انه
العمليه اوكي مجانا ولكن هاي المواد
الطبيه
بطبيعتها الامور رخيصه طيب انتم هل في
وعدتكم بذلك او شو رسالتكن حاليا ولمين
حاليا انا موجود انا خليني اسمح لي بس
معلش اني احرك الجوال خذ وقتك
شوف المشاهدة موجودين
مقابل انقاذ في 12 بنايه وراي موجودين
بخيمه بس خيمه بث مباشر موجود حاليا
باسم التطوعي لحتى
نسبه او الفاعل الناس شوي مثل ما الدول او
رؤساء الدول او او مسؤولين بالدول بيدعموا
نفسيا او معنويا الاشخاص اللي تضرروا بعد
سنه راح نعيد الاعمار او ما شابه احنا
حاليا اطلقنا صندوق اسمه قادرون لاعاده
اعمار المباني المتضرره خلال سنه واحده
باذن الله رب العالمين بيقدرنا حاليا
جمعنا على الموقع اكثر من اربع فاصله
مليون هلا بالاسم بث مباشر من حوالي
ساعتين هاي الحمله لمساعده الناس بانه
يتامل الوصلات الاغاثيه الثانيه عم تشتغل
الطبيه عم تشتغل بالطبي وعم ندعمها ان شاء
الله وعم بيصير في دعم من قبل الناس
الخارج والكونترات اللي عم توصلوا
الشاحنات الدوليه اللي تاخرت بس نحن حاليا
المنظمات التانيه انه او او المجتمع
الدولي انه يساهم بتاسيس او يساعدنا
باداره لانه نحن ما عندنا في اشياء يعني
اهم الاعادات الاعمار الان لاغاثه الناس
وهذه دعوه نامل ان تكون وصلت ساعود اليك
بس اشير الى الاخبار العاجله عن المرصد
سوريا يتهم النظام السوري بعدم السماح
بدخول القوافل انسانيه من مناطق الاداره
الذاتيه ويقول المرصد ان النظام يشترط
تسليم المساعدات له لتوزيعها عن طريق
الهلال الاحمر السوري المرصد السوري يقول
ايضا ان القوافل الانسانيه وكوادرها من
سوريين واجانب لا تزال تنتظر منذ 48 ساعه
عند معبر التايهه بريف منبج شرق حلب اذا
اخر الاخبار الوارده عن المرصد السوري
يتهم نظام الاسد
يعني اشتراك تسليم المساعدات له لتوزيعها
عن طريقه الهلال الاحمر السوري
ويرفض ويتهمه برفض دخول هذه القوافل
الى يعني
الكرديه القادمه من مناطق الاداره الذاتيه
للمناطق المنكوبه في حلب دون التنازل دون
التنازل عن شروط استاذ عاطف كنا استمعنا
الى عديد
يعني
من استضفناهم الذين تحدثوا عن فوضى في
توزيع المساعدات وعن تاخير وعن بيروقراطيه
وربما استمعنا الى الكثير من الاتهامات في
الايام السابقه ايضا بالاحتكارها بسرقتها
في
من جهات مختلفه في مناطق عديده على اختلاف
من يحكمها ماذا يمكن ان نقول في هذا
الاطار هل هناك معاناه حقيقيه بهذا الشان
بدايه ما في شيء غريب عن النظام السوري
نحن بنعرف هذا الحكي من زمان يرفض مساعدات
يسل الشعب شغلته يعني ما في داعي نرجع له
ونكرر من عشر سنين بالنسبه لموضوع الاخبار
السلبيه نحن عم نحكي عن هدر بالمساعدات
الانسانيه هذا ما بنحكي فيه بشكل سلبي بس
لحتى نحن والله نحكي انه عم يصير نعطيه
معلومه يقول نحن عنا اياها هلا الهدر بصير
بكل اوقات الكوارث لانه اصلا بيكون النظام
سقط النظام الصحي النظام الهبط النظام
الاغاثي خلاص الناس بتفوت ببعضها اصلا
الاشخاص الاغاثين او اللي بده يغيروا هم
اصلا اشخاص متطوعين الدفاع المدني بمركز
حارم انا موجود بمدينه حارم تمام تمام
متطوعين الدفاع المدني فما بالك بالشعور
اصدقائه وزبناء اللي بدهم ينقذوا اللي
بدهم ينقذوا الناس او حتى الانقاذ في
متطوع بالدفاع المدني فقط كل عائلته فما
بالك بالاشخاص او الاشخاص العمال
الانسانيين وينهم بدهم يروحوا تحت الانقاذ
متخيلين الحاله
للاسف فبالتالي
انتم قديش حدثكم بالفريق يعني هل قادرين
تصمدوا عندكم مقومات الصمود لكي تقدموا
المزيد من المساعده باختصار لو سمحت والله
والله نحن ساعه بنبكي منهار بشكل كامل
ساعه بنرجع بنرمم حالنا ونرجع اول وجديد
وضع نفسي جدا صعب ولكن ندعي رب العالمين
انه قدرنا حوالي 500 شخص بسوريا ودول
اللجوء
تطوعي الكل 24 ساعه
بيشتغلوا كل شي اكبر عدد من الارواح كل
العاملين منظمات الانسانيه عم بيشتغلوا كل
السوريين بالعالم عم يحاولوا انهم يساعدوا
في شغلات كتير ايجابيه بهالكارثه الا انه
الوجع كبير جدا جدا جدا على كل السوريين
والاتراك بكل مكان شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ
عاطف نعنوع من مدينه حارب في ادلب وانت
مدير فريق ملهم التطوعي نامل يعني ان
تعينكم الظروف على تجاوز هذه المحنه
تحياتي لك
[موسيقى]
تم نهب متجري بعد انهيار الجزء الخلفي
سرقوا اكثر من 70 الف ليره وبعضا من
البضائع التي نبيعها
[موسيقى]
متجرنا في حاله خراب لقد نهبه اللصوص
واخذوا ما امكن سرقوا كل المكان
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام نختم هذه الساعه ايضا
من تغطيتنا المتواصله من العربيه لزلزال
تركيا وسوريا ولكن الان زميل صهيب شراير
يتابع معكم في هذه التغطيه مع ارتفاع عدد
القتلى قتلى زلزال تركيا وسوريا سويا الى
نحو 35 الفا الى اللقاء